[Musique]
je m'appelle pierre sang boyer et la
cuisine c'est toute ma vie
ça fait plus de vingt ans que je mélange
des saveurs nouvelles et étonnante je
mets un petit fils naturel donné que les
herbes aromatiques avec le petit gigot
et c'est important de faire un petit
rappel et surtout donner un petit côté
un peu corsé quoi
je suis d'origine coréenne et je cherche
à fusionner des cuisines du monde
mon inspiration elle vient souvent de
mes voyages
à son voyage j'arrive à redécouvrir les
produits que je connais et surtout à
vouloir le partager avec un maximum de
personnes
[Musique]
la cuisine c'est une recherche
permanente alors je vais repartir en
voyage à la découverte de nouvelles
saveurs
et cette fois je compte bien embarquer
un copain avec moi un autre aventurier
du goût
g
c'est cédric graulhet il a été élu deux
fois meilleur pâtissier du monde
ça sent bon bah je suis fait la toile
c'est un véritable artiste
il est connu dans le monde entier pour
ses desserts unique
des fruits en trompe l'oeil
surtout qu'ils font mais regarde ce que
tu fais tu te prends mais tu crois que
dans direct vas-y
je suis un grand fan de son travail
j'ai un petit projet sympa c'est avec
courage
avec la découverte de la gastronomie
dans un pays que je connais pas la vie
sans dit ça te dit qu'on parte a
instruit le toit allez on y va
[Musique]
nous voici à jeddah la porte d'entrée du
pays
[Musique]
c'est une grande ville portuaire sur la
mer rouge dans le centre historique ça
grouille d'activités et c'est comme ça
depuis des siècles est la maison bleue
c'est magnifique
ici on est sur l'ancienne route de la
soie avec toutes les épices qui
transitaient entre l'asie et l'europe
[Musique]
alors forcément avec cédric on envie de
commencer le voyage par le souk aux
épices
et d'entrée de jeu les couleurs et les
odeurs nous sautent au visage
[Musique]
elle est l'auteure allait incroyable ça
sent très bon
pas de
la même
eau
c'est incroyable benoît sur safran
c'est à cannes à
la taille
mais combien de temps que 0,7 voilà du
coup j'avais la moitié de
[Rires]
ça c'est vraiment beaucoup
à ce produit
c'est le citron noir
l'un des ingrédients préférés de cédric
monziols
j'écris un citron noire à paris et j'ai
utilisé ce citron préféré
l'utiliser avec du citron jaune et on le
mélange avec le sucre en moi et c'est un
goût extraordinaire
j'ai rencontré ce citron noir il ya je
pense il ya six sept ans de les
retrouver ici à des milliers de
kilomètres de chez moi et de entendre
l'histoire comment ça a été fait je
trouve que ça nous apprend et ça nous
permet de le respecter le produit et de
l'expliquer je fais un citron noir et
pourquoi je le fais et comment je le
fais et je trouve que c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant donc on a de la chance
d'être là en fait
et je les bois
[Musique]
et tous les détails qui seront 800 ans
c'est quoi dingue
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à vous allez vous vous
êtes les bienvenus dans la zone
historique
une très jolie ville un patrimoine de
l'unesco cette fleur on la voit beaucoup
à paris sous les plafonds entre
énormément également cette fleur là je
sais plus son nom aucun seuil et là je
les ai utilisé exactement je pose des
desserts en plein milieu et je trouve ça
fait joli ça s'use après c'est vrai les
fleurs c'est toujours joli c'est élégant
août c'est vrai l'os go on continue on
dit on et comment diyala
j'ai donné rendez-vous à dire parce
qu'il connaît la vieille ville comme sa
poche
je lui ai demandé de nous faire
découvrir ces cons des plus secrets
regardez cette beauté alors j'ai tectura
les incroyables jolie ses idées mais
maison préférée elles sont jolies mais
celle ci voulait pas de problème
extraordinary les détails qui a de
chaque balcon
c'est jolie fenêtre comme vous voyez
elles sont un peu grande c'est pour que
ce soit une source de lumière à une
source de ventilation et les dames
pouvaient rester regarder tout elle
n'avait pas besoin de mettre le foulard
je m'attendais pas du tout à ça cette
ville est une pépite ou plutôt un
diamant brut il ya plein de choses à
voir a toujours des surprises mais c'est
génial
et qu'est ce que vous faites là on va où
là c'est à quelque chose que vous aimez
quelque chose qu'on aime faites
attention parce que moi j'aime beaucoup
de choses
surtout la nourriture ont prévenu les
oui c'est une boulangerie qui a commencé
en 1920 avec le four traditionnel
les odeurs cédric c'est incroyable
ça sans bobo on peut goûter une ça ça
m'intéresse vraiment hybride au cap ba
oui attention c'est chaud ah oui c'est
vraiment bon c'est différent c'est bon
tu vois ce qu'il est en train de faire
ouais j'étais à mon père il m'a envoyé
en boulangerie pour me faire un rendre
compte la difficulté du métier donc
j'étais à sa place et j'ai toute la nuit
j'attaque à 23h minuit et toute la nuit
je dis je des fourni comme ça devant le
four je vais conclure mais c'est un
travail et c'est un travail de lobbying
dans lesquelles j'avais 14 ans à 92 ans
mon père mené à 23h minuit à la
boulangerie
c'est incroyable
a comme ça
ok
tri
ça fait 22 ans que je fais des
pâtisseries du pain et j'ai l'impression
quand j'ai ouvert cette porte j'ai fait
un bond de 22 ans à l'arrière
quand j'étais gosse ma mère et mon père
ni directement au travail ça a été hyper
hyper dur il voyait que j'apprenais pas
l'école que j'étais très manuelle jeu
partait dans tous les sens ils savaient
pas quoi vraiment faire quoi de moi et
j'ai demandé de faire du pain parce que
je pensais quand j'étais petit qu'il
fallait faire du pain pour pouvoir faire
des gâteaux je ne savais pas qu une
pâtisserie existé je viens d'un village
relativement très très simple où il ya
personne et mes parents m'ont envoyé
dans la boulangerie et ma mère c'était
la première fois que je la voyais aussi
heureuse d'avoir des réflexions aussi
positive de mon travail et l ain elle
m'a dit je m'en souviens de cette phrase
elle me dit et cédric qu'est ce que tu
as fait qu'est ce que tu as fait ou
patrons et les fans de toi et dictent a
un talent incroyable j'ai mangé rien
fait juste et du pain
je suis heureux de voir cédric retrouver
la passion de son enfance il y a le feu
sacré et ça saute aux yeux
j'adore je suis fan c'est incroyable ce
travail c'est incroyable
merci tu veux cher on se
bat
maintenant on va partir dans cette jolie
maison l a140 année
en arabie lorsqu'on arrive chez
quelqu'un ou nous offre toujours des
dates en signe de bienvenue
c'est un produit incontournable ici mais
je crois que séverine on raffole pas
vraiment je n'aime pas les dates en
france jean gouttes
tous les fournisseurs essaye de
montgrand des dates je ne veux pas
travailler la date et je suis arrivé ici
on m'a fait goûter un café café blond
café blanc avec de la cardamone à
l'intérieur et ont amené une date emma
on m'a demandé de faire l'aller retour
entre ces deux là et là j'ai compris
vraiment la cardamone et la date j'ai
compris que je pourrais en faire quelque
chose enfin les allers retours entre la
date et le et le café je vais créer un
dessert à paris un radar car demain
c'est en fait on un aller retour entre
le sucre et le côté puissant de la rage
est
exactement comment je vais faire un
praliné et qu'une
date
computer qui semblent immenses créé
cellaic narines la texture la chair
c'est au mas biscuits ans tandis que la
peinture
ça vous allez voir je vais créer
ce voyage commence très fort à peine
arrivé cédric a déjà une nouvelle idée
de recette il va maintenant falloir
trouver des balles
[Musique]
direction le désert d'al oula
apparemment c'est la bague on trouve les
meilleures dates
[Musique]
les paysages défilent et on aperçoit des
formations rocheuses surprenantes
comme sortis de nulle part
oui
[Musique]
je sens cette liberté
ouais l'auvent la charles tous les sens
la nature la
regarde montrer
[Musique]
j'ai pas combien la hauteur ça va faire
50 mètres et
je pense vraiment
[Musique]
mais le plus spectaculaire
ce sont des monuments taillé à même la
roche
il y en a une centaine autour de nous ce
sont les tempes de la civilisation
n'abattait
celle un effet
comment ils ont fait pour tailler ça
c'est pas possible
[Musique]
tout est pure
extraordinaire franchement je suis je
suis
je ne sais pas quoi dire suif
ça mérite d'être connue dans le monde
entier ça mérite d'être
respecté ça mérite d'être vu
[Musique]
chanter c'est vrai
le bâtiment plus de 2000 ans canal alpha
uni et sanaa
et à moukalla
pour moi c'est une oeuvre d'art c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui allait
s'amuser s'est ouvert pour moi
j'aimerais juste avoir une idée du temps
pour faire ça
comme li na
jamais pouvoir ali ben naceur les
alimentaires halal bab azzoun à achat et
la oumma vaudeville fatras d'inventer
[Musique]
mais
m
oui
[Musique]
cette nuit on a invité pour un repas
traditionnel sous les étoiles on va
goûter la vraie cuisine du désert alors
pour l'occasion on a revêtu l'habit
traditionnel
comme bhv à
la
crise a le droit comme tel alors ce
technique là je les fais et surtout je
vu dans différents pays a déjà vécu ça
nous sommes d'accord mais après chaque
pays avec ses caractéristiques
ok mais ça change le goût ça change le
c'est quoi l'objectif de faire ça en
fait la technique c'est une technique
par concentration et condensation ça
veut dire que ça cuit dans une
casserole ou on va l'étouffer totalement
de sable et de branches normalement ok
après ça dépend des pays ce qui fait que
c'est comme si tu qu'ils aient quelque
chose dans une cocotte-minute mais de
façon très douce et de façon naturelle
donc ce soir à manger quelque chose
d'ici 20 ans original exactement
on va la cuisine pierre c'est ça oui là
on va voir leur four
c'est ici
ça n'a l'air de rien mais le fond de
sable c'est un sacré travail
ils ont dû creuser pour placer des
braises au fond du trou et laissez cuire
pendant des heures je vais pas faire des
vraiment
waouh
la pression baissière et trésors qu'on
va découvrir pierre
[Musique]
couleurs l'auteur
ça fait combien de temps que ça cuit
comme ça
avec des citrons
juste ronde ici
old
school en
toi qui adore le citron rua bleu citron
noire vécue être le riz
si je retrouve mon des sables paris ici
c'est une façon différente comme la
viande et en fit à
contenir
laurie
le riz ils font dans la bouche c'est
grâce à cette cuisson parce que là le
riz quand je viens de manger il est
vraiment un train de fondre comme du
beurre c'est extraordinaire
la
maladie
mort
d'annick goutal mari elle alors voilà
c'est
délicieux c'est
l'un des meilleurs
morceaux d'agneau que j'ai mangé de ma
vie à ce point là et j'en ai mangé j'en
ai fait des restait jamais
radio dans un trou de sable et c'est
extraordinaire déçu
[Musique]
moi je dirais simple à qui devrait être
classé au patrimoine de l'unesco
à l'image du où on est
on parle de sacré ça ferait partie des
plassac répondre
ce voyage est un fantastique
on a ceux plus l'âge d'être accueilli
dans un pays
où les gens nous accueillent
une façon extraordinaire qu'on se
cuisiner ou pâtissiers on est d'abord
des enfants on est d'abord des gens
curieux des gens passionnés par notre
métier
puisqu'il nous fait le plus plaisir
c'est d'être là
pouvoir partager pouvoir goûter poser
des questions
ça nous permet de
donner du sens à ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
après une nuit magique
cette nouvelle journée s'annonce encore
riche en découvertes gastronomiques
nous allons visiter une oasis c'est
incroyable de voir tout cette végétation
ou six dans un environnement aussi
arrive
bonjour bonjour
ici il ya plein de palmiers dattiers
je sens que ça va faire plaisir à cédric
la halle berry eloi warshaw dit
le
banana
40 types de dettes quand même c'est
énorme
[Musique]
les femmes aussi
incroyable
[Musique]
il ya rien de plus magique que manger
des frites qui ont été ramassés de
l'arbre
[Musique]
waouh aouidat quoi bon la femme merci
l'ordinaire
baldé majdal saga ajoie
incroyable de couleur du caramel copie
km - secret quoi bon ben on fait tout en
décalages à battre
je viens d'apprendre et de comprendre
qu'il y avait des différentes dates des
différentes variétés de dattes donc des
goûts différents des textures
différentes et aujourd'hui j'ai mon
palais vient de s'ouvrir sur les dates
et je vais pouvoir y travailler dessus
[Musique]
moi je pense que la dette après je vais
faire à paris tu vas sa lettre cette
couleur là tu vas marbre et comme ça
rires la transparence qu'il ya le marbre
âge s'est mariée mais c'est magnifique
on dirait un peu lâche le champignon des
mourides ont nourri un c'est beau ça
aujourd'hui tu ça exactement comme celle
là je vers
[Musique]
le saf et nacre c'est magnifique
je peux garder avec moi ça je vais
ramener à paris c'est la can les
fraudeurs et ana marisa syndicats
[Rires]
[Musique]
à aller à moustache et seuls
15 on ramasse pas sur scène même avis
oui la richesse
et donc du coup pour arriver à cette
date là si bonne est-ce qu'il faut
attendre cinq ans qu'il faut attendre
dix ans baptisera
et en référence à la ouate de motifs 9
depuis que je suis ici toutes ces
informations là je les prends je les
écoute pour faire un dessert trompe
l'oeil c'est vraiment ma marque de
fabrique ça fait une dizaine d'années
que je fais des desserts en trompe
l'oeil et je pense que ça serait cool
d'avoir une date suite à ce voyage
[Musique]
dan carter
tu vois moi je préfère les deux
créations de plus
onctueuse tu as quand je touche regarde
plus moelleux
je me dis que ça va être moins dur
tu sais j'aimerais créer un dessert en
forme d'une date jibril il me faudrait
beaucoup de dates à paris pour pouvoir
fabriquer les dates est ce que tu
pourrais me livrer des dates à paris non
moi j'ai besoin d'une date qui soit très
peu sucré pour pouvoir donner aux
personnes qui vont venir acheter mes
desserts avoir des choses beaucoup moins
sucré
lois lane et de ce co2 mais john ware
evans à l'heure ce gars
là encore le ban
c'est la meilleure date que j'ai mangé
de ma vie quand je les jetais ouverte
c'est la texture les couleurs elle
développe des arômes très intéressant
elle ne colle pas trop dans le nez pas
trop sucré donc ça c'est quelque chose
que qui m'attire parce que moi en tant
que pâtissier si c'est trop sucrés j'ai
du mal à y travailler avec et là je
trouve que ça va vraiment un goût très
intéressant
[Musique]
on continue notre voyage en visitant des
ruines d'un ancien village
depuis peu la région s'est ouverte au
tourisme et de nouveaux restons se sont
implantées
je crois que cette fois c'est cédric qui
veut me faire une surprise
tabiou on est fiers ouais j'ai jamais me
croit il ya une pâtisserie ici et à ce
qu'il paraît on va pouvoir les goûter
aux pâtisseries une pâtisserie plein
lieu de 2 à 7 tentés d'aller faire les
négociations je suis vraiment curieux de
goûter j'ai hâte de voir ça
[Musique]
alors ton croit maintenant ça sent bon
bonjour à l'ogc nice
[Musique]
l'as déjà on connaît une partie je pense
les macarons à ça j'ai connu ça sarko
n'est hélas je connais pas du tout mais
celui qui en triangle c'est le temps
bien on dirait un cheesecake on goûte
quelque chose alors c'est quoi qui te
fait plaisirs toi alors moi
je voudrais bien le cheesecake
le fromage me manque le podium
ok mais moi je pense que je vais prendre
le chocolat j'aime bien le chocolat
[Musique]
merci c'est vrai que c'est pas nous
c'est magnifique
[Musique]
on commence à l'est
je te certes
tu vois là ça a été très onctueux très
moelleux et quand je mange un dessert
n'hésite pas à manger je ne fais pas le
pâtissier ça veut dire décortiquer
chaque chaque élément de la pâtisserie
c'est je mange pour de vrai pour
vraiment ressentir les éléments qui sont
dans le désert tu pourquoi non jfl
france à rien tac
j'ai tout en bouche au moins
je ressens tout ce qui se passe dans
l'axé et là qu'est ce que tu décris
c'est un gâteau que jamais goûté quelque
chose de nouveau pour -
avoir la texture quand tu dois en bouche
et ce à la fois mousse à la fois cuit
onctueux
c'est surprenant
moi je sais pas mais je trouve que la
pâtisserie est deux fois plus appréciés
dans le monde que la cuy sur le sucre
c'est l'enfance je précisais ça mais
quand on parle des pâtisseries et bien
c'est pour célébrer un moment un moment
important de la vie les mariages
anniversaires noël la saint valentin on
offre un dessert et ce moment là je
trouve qu'il est il est important il
célèbre quelque chose de joyeux et donc
du coup je pense que notre métier on dit
souvent oui c'est que des gâteaux mais
c'est pas seulement des gâteaux c'est de
faire plaisir à quelqu'un qu'on aime
[Musique]
ce matin chez nouvelle surprise pour
cédric
schille embarque pour une partie de
pêche sur la mer rouge
non mais t'as vu le nombre de cannes et
le nombre de leurs kia et à toutes les
couleurs toutes les formes toutes les
tailles ses rêves de gosse
good on may god tellement contente
du fou
j'avais pas vu abba avec sa pierre
franchement tu ne faut pas la honte 1 on
ramène du poisson parce que là il ya
trop de matériel on n'a pas le chevalier
j'espère juste
[Musique]
cédric et moi on partage la même passion
pour la pêche on a tous les deux grandi
en auvergne et c'est une autre passe
temps préférés
mais là c'est la première fois qu'on va
pêcher ensemble
avec notre travail on n'a plus la
possibilité de pêcher ou moins en tout
cas et aujourd'hui c'est un cadeau c'est
un cadeau de la vie d'avoir la
possibilité de se retrouver tous les
deux ça fait des années et des années
qu'on en parle et de la chance qu'on a
il ya le soleil pas de vagues et les
amis et a les cannes à pêche mais on est
là à la cool c'est trop bien
[Musique]
je suis au travail en mode chasseur pire
et il ouvre le bal à bas ah oui
elle est hyper
positive
roots
band à ce petit chien ça sent le poisson
la
hâte en pierre laisse les pros et
amateurs l'arrière
la passion la pêche est devenue un des
mandats arrivée en france
étant arrivé j'avais de quel âge sept
ans et demi je lâche ans b comme cédric
de grandir à la campagne et ne sachant
pas pas forcément parler la langue j'ai
compris que dans la nature je pouvais
tout est plein de choses qui puissent
m'aider à m'intégrer
dont la pêche ça m'a permis de m'ouvrir
d'autres horizons
de comprendre un peu plus la vie comment
ça fonctionne et sûr de trouver ma voie
ça m'a donné envie de faire le métier
que je fais aujourd'hui
son poisson
[Musique]
et eau
pour l'instant voir un attrapé à 0 pour
les poissons
comme tous les pêcheurs le savent il ya
des jours où la mère ne me rien donné
mais on ne lâche pas la faire on va
utiliser le sonar le gps pour trouver un
meilleur spot
et le dip ya eu toutes les peines des
ris de bench
j'ai commencé avec un k morceaux de bois
et un fils de pêche et une sauterelle on
est avec un avec des salles et et on
colporte te dire que on a changé de vie
[Musique]
on a cherché le poisson et on rentre à
la maison
[Musique]
vaches
j'en ai un yes les gros ski sport en
faites
vous yes je suis crevée
pierre à 0
31 points sont au moins de jouer sur
youtube ce moment de pêche ce matin
c'était génial parce que vous c'est
génial de pouvoir partager avec des amis
et la chose qui était rigolote c'est que
l'on n'a pas attrapé beaucoup de
poissons et à la fin on a utilisé une
technique qui vendent ici on a pu pêcher
uniquement avec un hameçon un plomb un
fil et avec nos mains
je remets mes attraper un poisson
[Musique]
on a pu nager dans les coraux on avait
vraiment des poissons de toutes les
couleurs
c'était fantastique c'était très tôt
[Musique]
j'ai essayé d'attraper un ou de poisson
parce que l'on a très peu pêché
aujourd'hui en ligne mais non on est
reparti bredouille
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'était pas franchement
une pêche miraculeuse
alors avec cédric on décide d'aller au
marché aux poissons
on a envie de savoir à quoi ressemble
les espèces locales de la mer rouge
ça c'est bénéfique sa poissons
perroquets à ces perroquets des
universités une richesse
si mon impression c'est que ray de la
nature déjà la cible au fournil est la
couleur du coup leurs yeux
à ce magnifique journée
je pensais pas qu'ils aient autant qu'en
seconde période et ont la réponse
pierre
foucault sur 2 assas et le wahoo savez
que dans le
jeu magie mois
en ligne nike
hockey
[Musique]
cachette aux boissons thual comme ici je
vais préparer tu repars avec rien
abéché pu rendre
les calamars
[Musique]
tu enlèves le bec là on enlève la partie
acquise le mec comme ça
ça hop comment vous aimez le manger vous
saute
moi j'adore juste avec un juteux pour ça
c'est juste poêlé avec de l'ail perfidia
d'un simple avec un trait de vinaigre
mais ce qui est clair
c'est que le produit les perfect voilà
sont de la merde
[Musique]
à djeddah les produits de la mer sont
omniprésents
pour
et pour en savoir plus j'ai donné
rendez-vous à deux chefs saoudien
mohammed abdul
bonjour
alors les poissons s'apparente à ce
qu'on trouve en france mais on est
vraiment surpris par la qualité est ce
que je disais à cédric j'aimerais bien
que des gens comme vous puissiez nous
faire goûter ses poissons la cuisiner
avec à votre style
[Musique]
mohamed abdoul m'ont expliqué qu'ils
sont partis se former aux états unis au
prix des plus grands chefs et là ils
viennent de rentrer en arabie pour
démarrer leur business c'est toi qui
prépare les poissons ou est-ce que tu
n'aies fibré var est ici ce qu'on a vu
avec pia tout à l'heure qui préparaient
toutefois sont ici
c'est en fournisseur de poissons malades
comment tu vois le poisson si les frais
ou pas et je les wanna touch des
sketches et des femmes
de chenôve à
espelette
et cette semaine la
glycéro liga cinq buts est que
moi moi je suis attiré par les couleurs
et j'aime énormément celui ci est celui
ci j'aimerais bien voir les deux on voit
la différence pour que j'apprenne
sissouane celui-là est celui là un petit
re so on peut goûter les deux poissons
le n'at-il c'est le poisson préféré du
saoudien qui le consomment en friture
j'ai trop envie de manger là le goûter
mais moi mais d abdoul vent le cuisiner
différemment
[Musique]
les deux chefs nous emmène dans le
centre ville de jeddah
où ils ont installé leur
ce un concept plutôt original pays
donc là les poissons qu'on a acheté ce
matin au marché vous allez les préparer
c'est
génial parce que la dextérité qui l'a et
carizzma
c'est que déjà la scène professionnelle
les produits de fous qui ont tangué d'un
coup
c'est vrai que j'aime bien cuisiner
comme ça des produits simples quoi la
grille et la
ctu c'est comme hier c'est convivial je
pense à la beauté là et
cette cuisine là que vous faites c'est
cuisine
traditionnelle vous direz c'est une
cuisine personnelle
m
la diète
et algues ou grillés bien la poule à là
franchement je suis vraiment fan ça
c'est super sympa
ici le charme on dégage une superbe
odeurs car il est fabriqué à partir
d'une essence locale de bois qui va
imprégner une nouvelle saveur aux
poissons
pendant la cuisson le chef va nous faire
goûter le poisson cru en guise d'entrée
[Musique]
ça fait du bien de se faire sa vierge
qui
arrête ta chanson tu viens à la maison
je te sers c'est vrai
ça fait du bien parce que le début en
fait nous accueillent vraiment avec une
simplicité incroyable là on est en train
de cuire un poisson sur une grillade et
c'est très accueillants très simple et
on passe un bon moment ça fait du bien
salle aragon
eh bien moi je conseille
ce bruit des magic avec ce côté creux
use ou le poivre
pour y attendre et des pick
up des faits voilà c'est bon ça
merci beaucoup
c'est tellement beau et
c'est pas fini le poisson grillé au
barbecue est enfin prêt on va pouvoir le
déguster
[Musique]
la façon de cuisiner j'ai vraiment aimé
le poisson quand ils ont posé sur les
braises j'ai vraiment apprécié de manger
avec les doigts avec une pointe de fleur
de sel et de manger avec il y avait à
peine de l'huile d'olive j'ai ressenti
une cuisson de poissons
comme on l'est on fait comment m et des
fois on dit que d'en faire trop ça ne
sert à rien et là je pense que c'était
parfait
[Musique]
pire on sait ce qu'on aime tous les deux
on hamm est bon moment et je pense qu'on
a passé
[Musique]
avant de partir
moi mais des atours nous ont conseillé
de goûter à l'autre spécialité de la
région
les agrumes
tu crois que ça radié du fruit
waouh tout ce vert en plein milieu du
désert ça va être des faux on découvre
des fruits magnifique qui pousse dans
une oasis à l'extérieur de la ville
assez des citrons percement de citron
mais lesquels je pense que je pense que
la barre était à citrons jaunes simple
ici je suis sûre que cédric est dans son
élément
c'est clair qu'il ya des fruits vraiment
partout et pour cédric c'est une matière
première formidable rien de sarko mais
c'est bon
aa de support à la mêlée c'est
incroyable ce que la nature peut nous
offrir quoi
quand tu dis bébé
direct le coup de couteau rien rien
incroyable
ce que j'aime c'est ça
on
croyait la texture ce fruit largement
serge seulement pour les aime les
desserts de restaurant gastronomique
comment tu fais pour donner de l'émotion
sur le dessert sûreté création je pense
c'est que les gens et les clients quand
ils viennent manger mes desserts
j'imagine qu'ils sont aveugles j'imagine
toujours qu'ils sont aveugles qui
n'aiment pas les décès remonte plus fin
du coup c'est les gens les plus
critiques qu'ils aillent chez moi si je
fais un dessert au chocolat ou si je
fais un dessert la poire ou si je fais
un dessert à la preuve est bien la
première bouchée qui va mettre en bouche
je veux qu'il ressente
quelque chose qu'il a déjà ressenti
auparavant ça veut dire quand il était
petit il a mangé sa première pole sa
première foire son premier morceau de
chocolat et là moi qu'ils avaient un
souvenir et j'ai envie de les recréer ce
souvenir et pour recréer ce souvenir eh
bien je ne vais pas mélanger plein de
saveurs je vais me concentrer sur la
meilleure saveur que je connais pour
essayer de créer un des meilleurs
desserts du monde et je pense que si je
mélange trop de saveur dedans j'appelle
ça la salade de fruits du coup on ne
sait pas ce qu on dit j'ai envie de
donner une vraie identité mais dessert
ça y est notre voyage touche à sa fin
on va bientôt rentrer à paris où cédric
va imaginer son nouveau dessert à la
date
mais avant le départ pour n'en veut
faire un dernier petit kiff une visite
dans les dunes
[Musique]
et l'eau fuck you think you merci aux
glasgow pour y accéder on doit changer
de véhicule et ça tombe bien ce truc et
moi on est fan de sports mécaniques
décollage imminent
gamin
[Musique]
ouf on va papa
c'est incroyable
ce que j'apprécie avec le calme car je
donne un peu de sérénité
[Musique]
oh
hier la dernière photo dans le sable que
tu te faire pleurer toi dernière photo
voilà ça touche la fin à un long gant
on a eu la chance de goûter les plus
beaux produits l'arabie saoudite moi je
retiendrai des émotions
est partagée aussi un autre métier que
notre passion que côté personnel ces
valeurs là c'est les valeurs qui font
que
quand on se sent bien
je pense qu'un voyage télé rencontre
mais c'est aussi la possibilité de
grandir de se structurer de prendre du
recul sur soi même donc ce voyage m'a
fait du bien et m'a rendu heureux et ne
m'a rendu plus fort pour demain
[Musique]
on
pierre seillant la fête j'ai réussi à
faire la date avec mes équipes là ça
marche trop bien fois
je t'attends pour venir goûter cette
pointe de cardamone avec avec la date à
l'intérieur hyper fraîche et en plus je
t'ai mis un petit zeste de citron je
sais que tu adores ça
[Musique]
donc je t'attends matrix